[Music]
[Applause]
Ross Tucker CBS Westwood one color
analyzed host of the Ross Tucker
football podcast the uh former NFL
lineman he was on the call Bengals
Ravens last night for Westwood one check
him out on social media at Ross Tucker
NFL
let me start with last night with uh
Lamar Jackson game-winning drive you got
Justin Tucker as a weapon there they
played pretty good defense
um
I guess handicapped the Ravens here how
good are the Ravens
yeah I think right now they're probably
the third best team in the AFC I think
the bills and the Chiefs then are still
probably one two because the Ravens have
had some issues holding on the leads
they almost blew another one last night
but they're the other team in the AFC
that I can see possibly going to the
Super Bowl I struggle seeing another
team and I envisioned going to the Super
Bowl from that conference it really
feels like we're headed towards a bills
Chiefs you know collision course but I
do think the Ravens could be in that mix
they're talented enough the way Lamar
Jackson plays they can get in and the
Justin Tucker thing is amazing I mean
Dan he's made 61 straight field goals in
the fourth quarter overtime he made a
58-yarder at one point last night I was
thinking about this you know you watch
the red zone or you watch the games
so many of them come down to a kicker
missing a kick you know the Browns kid
York missed it the kid Amendola for the
Cardinals missed his kick I can't even
imagine how good of a feeling it is for
the Ravens to know like our guy never
miss it like any time we get in that
situation game's over we won I mean they
didn't need to have him kick it it's
crazy
assess the Bengals after last year's
performance of going to the Super Bowl
I think they're going to be in the mix I
would be surprised they don't make the
playoffs they have a really good still
young defense I don't think we talk
about Lou annarumo their defensive
coordinator enough they haven't given up
a touchdown in the second half all year
so far this year the issue they're
having right now Dan everybody saw what
they did last year everybody saw the big
plays down the field and they're saying
we're not going to let you have it we're
not going to let you do it two deep
safeties kind of like teams did against
the Chiefs a year ago two deep safeties
are you patient enough to keep taking
the underneath stuff will you run the
ball against a light box will you throw
the wide receiver screens they're not
going to let Chase and Higgins beat them
deep
um we had an over correction it felt
like after Tua got hurt that you saw
this with Bridgewater Teddy's out after
the first play doesn't come back the Tom
Brady sack that uh was roughing the
passer here
um
we see this it feels like every year
there's one call like we're gonna call
past interference we're going to call
holding you've got to complete the
process like all of these things it's
one moment but here we are mid-season
and we've changed a rule
where are we headed with this Ross
it's a great question uh those to me on
some level are two separate things I
want to dive into so on the Teddy
Bridgewater thing Dan they said he
passed all the concussion protocols but
that the spotter saw him stumbling which
I don't even know how to say the word
Ataxia or something gross motor
instability
I don't know anybody else that saw it
like I mean I would love to see the
video because I didn't see Bridgewater
stumbling from a hit to the head but now
that's why they're saying you can go
back in the game but now it's the eye
test not the medical test
right but at least the eye test with Tua
we all saw it the eye test with Teddy
none of us all it's almost like they
just thought we just shouldn't put them
back in after what happened to this team
before that I mean we got to see the
gross motor instability maybe it was
when he was on the sideline with them
and then the Brady thing you know I
might be the only person I got up after
three hours sleep Dan and did my podcast
this morning already I might be the only
person that's not bashing Jerome Boger
right now and here's why I talked to the
refs Dan they have been told
when in doubt throw the flag in terms of
player safety and in particular
protecting the quarterback if you look
at where Boger was located Grady Jarrett
slung Brady down
in boger's Direction so he saw Brady
come flying over now you and I realized
it was a bad call he's just bringing him
down it's a tackle but Boger has it in
his head when in doubt throw the flag
protect the quarterback he sees Brady
come plung over his default reaction is
to throw the flex number one let's get
rid of this when in doubt throw the flag
it's a terrible standard and number two
we got to have the ability to replay it
that could have been the difference in
the game that could be the difference in
seating in the playoffs it was an
obvious error and egregious call that we
need to give them a chance to correct
I'm not going to just bash Boger I'm
gonna bash the process that led to Boger
making that call yes but what happened
the last two weeks got us to this point
do you really think if Bailey's zappy of
the Patriots
was in the same situation they would
have made the same call of roughing the
passer no I don't I think it's like
every time Michael Jordan went to the
hole in the 90s right he was going to
get the call on the foul Brady and
Rogers especially Brady they get the
benefit of the doubt even more so than
the other quarterbacks do but they have
been told that them and they have been
told the same thing with any hits to the
head or neck area of a defenseless
receiver same goes in college I'm on
those calls those you know at the start
of the Year those seminars when in doubt
throw the flag they do that with
targeting and college football drives me
nuts when in doubt throw the flag I
don't know why that needs to be the
standard do you think players want to be
protected do you think these
quarterbacks want to be viewed this way
yes I do yeah I mean
I think you think Brady
do you think Teddy Bridgewater wants to
be treated that way
I think Teddy Bridgewater probably
wanted to go back in the game but I do
think on some level these guys we've
evolved enough that I think on some
level
some of these guys realize better safe
than sorry I'm gonna flip those Dan
can you imagine if what happened to
Bridgewater happened to Brady and they
tried to let him go back and yeah but
we're headed towards something that's
going to happen in the playoffs Ross
we're we're headed towards that I had a
source who works with the NFL who said
there's going to be an over correction
said this last week because of this and
I said well what happens if this happens
in in the playoffs and my source said
that quarterback comes out of the game
yeah I I think it is going to happen and
it is an over correction and then in
this off season they'll go to the
owner's meetings and they'll kind of
fine tune it and they'll they'll have
different language this is this is
you've already said it Dan it feels like
almost an annual thing that there's
something that happens and the NFL
reacts with an overreaction maybe that's
natural in life I don't know
we're talking to Ross Tucker now you can
follow him Ross Tucker football podcast
and uh he's on social media at Ross
Tucker NFL
I'm watching now do you take more away
from the Cowboys winning or the Rams
losing
it's a good question
um
probably the Cowboys winning you know
the Rams are really beat up on the
offensive line they lost two starters
this off season I'd like to see them
when they're healthy up front but the
Cowboys if you would have told me after
that opening night game against the
Bucks and Dak getting hurt that they
would win four straight that night their
offensive line looked horrendous
uh the receivers couldn't get open for
them to then I mean I thought they were
done I thought they were cooked Cooper
rush comes in wins four games and he's
been fine it's been primarily their
defense their defense is nasty
Armstrong's good Lawrence is good and I
think Micah Parsons is pretty clearly
the best defensive player in in the
league already
yeah I wonder about this
does that come back you know in a
showdown against the Eagles do you try
to you know push him through uh or do
you wait where you're going to be
playing you know the the Lions and the
Bears which to me makes more sense think
about the long term of the season but
with Jerry Jones you're you never know
it feels like it's like come on come on
let's go doc you got to get ready we
thought he's going to be playing against
the Rams now it's the Eagles this week
I think that they should wait till he's
truly 100 you know the last thing you
want is for him to go out there and bang
that thumb again on Hassan redick's
Helmet or Fletcher Cox's helmet you
better be real confident that if he hits
a helmet that he's fine and it's weird
then because on some level you're not
really putting him in position to
succeed right on the road at The
Undefeated Eagles but do you keep the
same game plan that you've had with
Cooper Rush
run first play good defense maybe come
up with a you know a threatening pass
play
I think it's a great point and I think
the answer is yes we're not going to
there's no way if that comes back
that he's going to go you know 13 of 22
for uh you know 178 yards it's just not
going to happen but you know what dude
he's in a bad spot man because what if
he let's say he comes back Sunday night
and they lose it's a bad look right I
mean I'm not saying anybody's gonna say
Cooper Rush should be the starting
quarterback over Dak I mean dak's a
better player but Cooper Rush is 5-0 4-0
this year the pressure isn't on DAC to
keep his job but the pressure's on that
to win because you know you don't want
to be the guy that comes back and then
they lose again and you're the only
thing that changed
all right help me understand the logic
of the Chargers and what happened with
Coach Staley going forward on fourth
down with a little over a minute to go
yeah I'm curious about that one I didn't
see what he said after the game I know
this okay
every decision a lot of these guys make
now they have the win probability
statistics for every situation right so
if we punt it here here's the percentage
chance that we win the game if we go for
it and get it it's 100 we win it if we
go for it and don't get it here's the
percentage a lot of times these guys are
making the decisions based on what the
win probability metrics tell them and
maybe the thought was
hey the Browns just went all the way
down the field and Jacoby Brissette blew
it by throwing a pick in the end zone if
we punt here they're gonna go down the
field again and they're going to get
another field goal attempt and we're
going to lose our best bet is to try to
go ahead and get the first down here
because even if we don't get it maybe
there's still time for Herbert to get a
field goal after the Browns get their
field goal yeah I didn't understand it
now it was explained to me after the
game you know maybe you know coach
Staley just has so much confidence in
his offense to go for it on fourth down
and so much confidence in his defense if
they don't get the first down against
the Cleveland Browns I'm like okay all
right I'll at least entertain that but
you're talking about this comes down to
analytics there's no other coach who
goes for it as much as Staley and the
Chargers do if they all have the same
analytics why don't more coaches go for
it in these situations
I think more coaches uh trust the
analytics than others right so I think
staling now listen there were a couple
times earlier in this season I can't
remember what game it was a Prime Time
game Thursday night I think maybe at
Kansas City where twice he didn't go for
it and all the analytics do I asked on
Twitter they all said those were both go
for it situations and he didn't so what
I don't like I know there should be some
gut feel to it but he's kind of toggling
back and forth now you know I mean I
know some college teams like Army just
goes by the book whatever the book says
they go with it the toggling back I
understand you taking account the
situation a little bit but you either
trust the numbers and you're going to go
with the higher probability and
percentage chance like you're in a
casino like you're bet in the house or
whatever you want to go with the best
odds or you don't Staley's going back
and forth it seems like I don't know
he's made the right decision yet
uh the big game tonight Raiders Chiefs
they're all big games but we're not
quite sure who the Raiders are I think
we have a good idea who the Chiefs are
would you say that fair assessment now
yeah they don't look like a team that
misses Tyree kill that much they look
like you can make a really strong
argument for the Chiefs as the best team
in football to me it's pretty clearly
right now the Chiefs bills and Eagles
feel like they're at a higher level than
the rest of the league
always great to talk to you thank you
absolutely thank you Dan thank you buddy
that's Ross Tucker CBS Westwood one
color analyst and host of the Ross
Tucker football podcast is great on
social media if you follow him it's
always some fun stuff